primera vez en 16 años que las mujeres
colombianas salen a manifestarse bajo un
marco legal donde el aborto la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
está permitido Y es que desde el pasado
21 de febrero la corte constitucional de
Colombia sacó el delito del aborto del
Código Penal hasta la semana 24 de
gestación tras ello impera el sistema de
tres causales que se logró despenalizar
desde el año 2006 esto es un hecho
histórico un fallo histórico para la
región y para Colombia y que se logró
gracias al movimiento feminista
concretamente al movimiento causa justa
una agrupación de más de 100
organizaciones feministas de la región Y
si bien ha habido muchas críticas entre
los sectores conservadores por la
extensión de las 24 semanas las
organizaciones médicas señalan que solo
el 1% de los abortos se practican tras
la semana 24 de embarazo el resto del
90% de los abortos se realizan antes de
la semana 15 de gestación hoy las
mujeres están aquí celebrando han
colocar los pañuelos verdes para
conmemorar este día pero también para
romperlas con las barreras que hay en su
implementación especialmente para las
mujeres Rurales para las mujeres
migrantes o para las mujeres afro e
indígenas que son las que están teniendo
mayores problemas a la hora de acceder a
un aborto legal seguro y gratuito como
decimos el tono aquí es festivo de
celebración y no solo se Está celebrando
en la ciudad de Bogotá sino también en
otras ciudades de Colombia